thanks for inviting me and there's been
a great workshop so far I hope I live up
to the task here my talk is much easier
than the previous one so hopefully you
know sit down relax okay so today I'll
talk about scaling algorithms and
deterministic approximation of capacity
and the Brass complete constant and you
know this beyond randomization because I
don't know any randomized algorithm well
deterministic is a randomized algorithm
or don't use randomness but you know
purely like better randomized algorithm
to compute like the BL constant for
example so the outline for today is I'll
talk about some scaling problems then
I'll give you some algorithms and I'll
show you how these approximate the
permanent end capacity and then we
switch gears and start talking about
Bres complete and then we conclude and
post some open problems okay so but you
know beyond even randomized algorithms
or even beyond just these two topics
that I'll talk about why should anyone
care about like scaling problems even if
you don't know what they are yet right
so they have applications everywhere so
in communication complexity algorithms
optimization quantum information theory
algebraic complexity representation
theory and you know so on so you know
you should care about this okay let me
give you
I mean I'll state my two motivation but
let me just give you a very simple
scaling problem okay which is the matrix
scaling problem suppose I give you an N
by n non-negative matrix a okay
and I say that this matrix is doubly
stochastic if this row sums and the
column sums are all one okay so here is
an example of a double stochastic matrix
okay and I say that B is a scaling of a
if there are positive real numbers X 1
up to xn or I 1 or 2 I n such that bij
is equal to X I a IJ Y J's so this means
that the x i's are going to multiply the
rows and the Y's are going to multiply
the columns ok so a has a double
stochastic scaling if there is a double
stochastic matrix
scaling beat of this matrix a okay so
for example this matrix here okay is a
matrix a it has a doubly stochastic
scaling because well here's my scaling
factors and I obtain the first matrix
okay so but now algorithmically speaking
we're not interested so much in the
exact W stochastic scaling problem we're
interested in the approximate W
stochastic problem so and what do I mean
by an approximate double stochastic
matrix let's just see let's just have
this measure of distance from a matrix a
from being doubly stochastic and what is
this this RI is the I throw some of a
the CJ is the jth column sum and I'm
just seeing how how far I am from being
doubly stochastic okay so this is the
double stochastic distance and the
question now is a has an approximately
double stochastic scaling if for all
epsilon there is a scaling be epsilon of
a such that this matrix B epsilon is
epsilon close to being doubly stochastic
okay now you know in computer science we
see this problem and we say well when
does a have an approximate doubly
stochastic scaling and can we find it
efficiently okay so these are the
questions we're going to be interested
in so okay and why does the approximate
problem is more important there are two
reasons one computational and one more
geometric okay for those of you who have
seen this talk before you know yeah yes
I apologize but I will go through this
again so the first example is
computational right like we cannot spit
out like like irrational numbers with a
computer so you know you can never hope
to obtain this W stochastic scaling you
will you're always gonna get something
really close computationally but
geometrically what can happen is that
you can have this matrix here okay and
this matrix okay you were always
approximate there's a scalar there
always approximate a double stochastic
scaling but you'll never be able to get
the exact double stochastic scaling
because you can never make this entry
here from now zero to zero right because
you're only multiplying by positive
numbers okay so only in the limit you
will get this
but you know now I hope I motivated that
the approximate problem is much more
interesting than the exact problem and
let me just show you an algorithm which
is very simple so suppose I give you
this matrix n by n and I ask is there
abso scaling to double stochastic I also
give you excellent ok how do we find it
and there are no people in the 30s
already just did the naive algorithm
that you would think ok so I pick my
matrix a if it's not row stochastic if
my rows are not one simply make the rows
one ok but now you messed up the columns
now what do you do well let's just fix
the columns again but then you mess up
the rows what you do well repeat this
many times and if at any point you get
very close to doubly stochastic you
output this W stochastic scaling or you
know if at some if at no point you know
you have the K times there if at no
point you got close you say well there's
no scaling now the only thing that's
left to do is to prove that this works
right but I mean three questions that we
have is one are we making progress at
all and how do we know when to stop
so how which case should we choose so
that this algorithm is correct and the
third question is well is there some
epsilon zero that if I can get epsilon
zero close doubly stochastic okay I can
get close to double stochastic for any
epsilon because maybe you know you want
some really high precision and you know
maybe I just need to test something
before just to decide whether you can
achieve that precision okay so let me
just run this algorithm for you with two
examples so we can see when does it work
and when does it fail right so okay
first I give you this matrix okay now
let's just scale the rows okay now the
matrix row stochastic now but I broke up
the columns and then again I scale and
then now I normalize the columns then I
broke up the rows okay and I keep doing
this and you see where this is going
right I'm never gonna get close now
suppose that I give you the second
matrix here okay now we do we scale the
rows okay but now I messed up the
columns then we scaled the columns
messed up the rows and we keep doing
this notice that these denominators are
always you know decreasing which is a
good thing and these numbers are you
know
becoming smaller as well and then at
some point I'm going to obtain this
matrix okay
so this is a row stochastic but it's
very close in the column scale so one in
one example I converge to a double
stochastic matrix the other one I'll
never get to double stochastic matrix so
how can we distinguish between these two
cases are these the only two okay so the
observation here is that in the first
example we have no matchings right and
therefore we have a hole blocker which
is this big block of zeros here right in
the second case I have a matching okay
so are these the only bad cases when I
have no matching so if I have a matching
can I always scale to W balanced okay so
let me show you the analysis of this
which was done by linear homogeneous
convicted son in 2000 and the analysis
is as follows well let's pick the
permanent of a okay so if I have a
matching right my permanent is bigger
than zero right because permanent is a
sum of product of all matchings and
suppose that you know my the entries of
my matrix a they are all bounded by 1
over nu okay so if I have one matching
right if my permanent is bigger than
zero then my permanent is bigger than
this new to the minus n right because
it's just the product of the interest of
the matching okay now if I'm far from
being doubly stochastic okay then they
show that when you normalize if you
normalize the rows of the columns okay
my permanent the value of my scale
matrix okay the permanent of that matrix
it will increase by a factor of e to the
e for each of the epsilon okay and we
know that the permanent is less than or
equal to 1 for any normalized matrix
right because the permanent is less than
the product of the row sums right so
therefore I can just choose K to be
polynomial n over epsilon and there's
also Phi's right so it decides whether
matrix can be scaled to double
stochastic or not okay great and we know
that you know permanent is bigger than 0
if and only if a has a matching so you
know those two cases are the only cases
right and the algorithm is correct
okay any questions so far okay now how
do we bound this epsilon0 remember
there's a third question okay what
epsilon0 should we choose that if you
have epsilon0 you can always scale right
well you know permanent of a is equal to
zero if and only if a has no matching
and has a hull blocker okay so now let
me just do a very simple proof now since
we talked so much about hard things in
the previous talk let's just see a
simple thing right so if my matrix a
okay it has a big block of zeros okay
let's say that here I mean what is the
big block of zeros is that you know if
this dimension is I this dimension is J
you just have the I plus J is bigger
than n which means that just I is bigger
than n minus J okay now let's name this
column c1 up to CI and these rows here
are 1 up to our n minus J okay well we
know right because I mean these are
non-negative right so we know that the
sum of our eyes well not is a bet letter
here our case right is greater than or
equal than the sum of the columns right
okay here as well right because there's
some of these columns here you have zero
you have only these entries and there's
some of the rows you have these entries
plus something that's maybe non-negative
right so suppose that I set my epsilon
not to be equal to 1 over 2 N squared
okay so I claim that no matrix that has
this big block okay can get this close
to being doubly stochastic okay why
because if you could write what would
happen you know that the sum of CI minus
1 squared not CI sorry CK minus 1
squared it would be less than 1 over 2n
squared which means that well all of
your CK's they are between 1 over 2n
plus one one minus one over two n right
so in particular this is bigger
remember this is K equals to 1 up to I
and this is K equals to 1 up to n minus
J right so in particular this is the
same for the rows right so the rows are
also in this range so then now what does
this mean this is the same as this is
bigger than I 1 minus 1 over 2 N and
this is less than n minus J 1 plus 1
over 2n right but since this is a
integers and you have this inequality
okay this cannot hold ok so you know you
have a really good bound your bound is
very small okay in this case so that's
how you bound
epsilon-not okay so we solved all of our
questions for matrix scaling okay and
it's an easy problem so you're all
pretty bored right now so let's get to a
harder problem okay so now let's get to
quantum operators which is a
generalization of the matrix scaling
problem so a quantum operator can be
given by any map ok the maps complex
matrices ok n by n matrices 2 n by n
matrices given by a tuple of matrices a1
up to a M such that T of X is equal to
this quantity here AIX a I conjugate
transpose okay the only thing I wanted
to get out of it is that it may it takes
positive semi-definite matrices to
positive semi definite matrices ok no
quantum things required here ok and the
dual of this map ok if you have just the
emission in your product here right this
dual map is given essentially by just
flipping this a conjugate dagger here so
is the sum of AI conjugate transpose x
AI ok so this is the dual map and now
since I defined this and I'm gonna tell
you that this is a generalization of
matrix scaling you asked first well
what's the analog of scaling here and
what is the analog of double stochastic
for this quantum operators ok and here's
a definition of doubly stochastic so my
quantum operator is going to be doubly
stochastic if the identity is a fixed
point of both T and a duo Matt ok so if
both T I and T do
why they map to dead entity now what is
a scaling a scaling of this map T
consists of two invertible matrices now
okay remember I had before diagonal
matrices in the matrix scaling but now I
have irritable matrices such that I
multiply all of the matrices AI
simultaneously on the left by L and on
the right by our okay so is this
left-right multiplication and what is
the analog of distance to double
stochastic well my distance of Kasich's
how far I am from being double
stochastic and here I have the l2 norm
if you think of these matrices it's a
vector okay so far so good
okay now again we say that T the
operator T has an approximate double
stochastic scaling for every epsilon
there exists this matrices L epsilon R
epsilon such that the scaled operator
has this double stochastic less than or
equal to Epsilon
okay same setting and again we can ask
the same questions when does a when does
my operator T which I'll denote by this
tuple of matrices now have an
approximately double stochastic scaling
and can we find it efficiently okay you
can also ask about the absol not okay
but I would just we can solve it as well
but yes these stochastic quantum
operators with a nice set with respect
to space
in this vector space some sense in a
very large dimensional vector space yeah
you're in the vector space right like
the diesel I mean you can consider this
is essentially being like Amen to the to
the M okay doubly stochastic had a non
negativity constant yes yes yeah right
now negativity constraint should be
respected Yeah right
right yeah yeah so okay so now let's see
how this generalizes the matrix scaling
okay and this just be a nice easy
exercise that we're gonna come back to
it later when we talk about breasts
complete so okay how does this
generalize matrix scaling simply take
this quantum operator given by this the
matrices AI are going to be root of a 1
1 times the elementary matrix e 1 1 so 1
1 in the entry 1 1 root of a 1 2 even 2
you get the pattern and the dual map
will simply be the a transpose right
what you get from the a transpose so now
you have a 2 root of 81 multiplying by e
1 2 okay so it's a very easy exercise
and then now let's look at what is T a
when you apply to the identity okay so T
a when you apply to identity you know is
this quantity here okay which if you sum
you only get like some of a IJ times II
III which means that you know in the
first diagonal you get the row sums of
your matrix and you know in the entry I
you get the sum of the row I okay and
the dual you can see that you get the
column sums in the diagonal okay so
simple exercise and so the distance
doubly stochastic of this operator ta is
exactly the matrix distance the doubly
stochastic okay so you can see how this
is a generalization of matrix scaling
and you can see well but the group
action here now maybe you have more
freedom but you can show that you know
essentially if you act on the group on
these matrices you only need to use
diagonal matrices as well so you know it
is essentially a strict generalization
now okay so we have our problem now
let's get to the algorithmic problem so
I give you an operator which I give you
by the vector of matrices a1 up to a.m.
and let's assume that these matrices now
have integer coefficients okay and
epsilon is bigger than zero that can t
be epsilon scale to double stochastic
and if yes let's find it so you know
birth weights after lots of
generalizations right he came up with
this problem and he also came up with
the algorithm which is well again repeat
k times okay so if my T of I is
different from the identity let's just
normalize it so how do you normalize you
multiply on the left all the matrices by
some invertible matrix to make T of I
equals to the identity okay now you're
gonna mess up the dual once you mess up
to do what you do well normalize the
dual okay and make T do all of I equals
to I and you keep repeating this okay
and if at any point you get close to
epsilon close to doubly stochastic you
output the current scaling otherwise you
just output no scaling and then now the
question is well which case should we
choose right so okay so how does the
analysis go groove it's also you know
generalizing on the previous analysis
it's like okay let's do the following
let's come up with a potential function
remember in the last in matrix scaling
our potential function was the permanent
itself but then Groovy's had to come up
with a different potential function
which is what he called the capacity
because it generalizes his capacity for
hyperbolic polynomials yes okay yes it's
an orthogonal generalization of the
basic capacity the first capacity right
the kid the first two so and the
capacity is the following take the
infimum over the determinant of t of x
divided by the determinant of X for all
over all positive definite matrices okay
if you know so verb it's also analyzed
the
the matrix scaling problem by using this
other function that he called capacity
so let me show you how this is a
generalization of that notion
so his capacity for matrix okay
so is equal to the income over all X 1
up to xn bigger than 0 of ax once you
multiply take the I've coordinate of
this guy and take the product over all
of them okay and divide by the product
of X I there's the first group of its
capacity and this capacity generalizes
that one that was you that can also be
used to analyze the matrix scaling and
Gurewitz came up with this capacity and
he said okay if capacity is bigger than
0 remember for the permanent right if
the permanent was bigger than 0 it was
lower bounded by something nice
Sammy versus exponential and then
Corbett said well if capacity is bigger
than 0 then capacity is bigger than I
don't know right and but he showed that
if the distance of doubly stochastic is
big and you normalize then your capacity
will also grow in the same way by this e
to the epsilon okay and it's easy to see
from this definition that the capacity
of T is less than or equal to 1 for
normalized operators right because you
can simply put the identity here this
will give you 1 and that's it right so
now all is left is to give a lower bound
on on this capacity and he was able to
give a lower bound on some on some cases
for this capacity but he was not able to
give the lower bound for overall cases
ok for all types of operators so ok so
now and in you know in our first work
what we did in 2015 was to if the
capacity is bigger than 0 then we give
this nice lower bound e to the minus
poly n ok which is all we needed for our
algorithm to work ok this is the
starting point of all this scaling
business for us ok but I mean the thing
is yeah
that uses some potential that's more
like the program yes yes yeah so that
there is and if I so I was this talk was
supposed to be 45 minutes the organizers
gave me 15 minutes more and if I if I
have the 15 minutes Gurewitz can talk
about what is the permanent yeah the
choice of RNC in the algorithm choosing
or and see what are good choices doesn't
matter no I mean you just essentially
you just really normalize you know I
mean once you get your tea I I mean
you're the either you the art that you
choose to normalize would be the inverse
square root of the of this guy right so
it's a canonical already like yeah yeah
so okay but then I mean the other
question that we need to figure out is
well when can we scale I mean when is
this capacity bigger than zero right I
mean well we have to show first that if
capacities like if you can scaled in
your capacity will be bigger than zero
right so when can we scale okay so in
matrix scaling we saw that you can scale
if and only if you don't have this huge
block of zeros right there's no hot
block or if you have a matching is there
an analog in the operator scaling case
and we're vids in 2005 he you know
provided that this condition to us okay
and the condition is as follows so this
tuple of matrix matrices is say it's
called rank non-decreasing if and only
if for all vector spaces okay for all
subspaces of the complex you have that
the dimension of this space when you
take the Union over all AI is applied to
V this dimension is bigger than the
dimension of your original space so it
is me well it really means that you're
not shrinking any subspace right so you
have your big complex space here CN and
you have your space V once you apply all
of them all of the AI okay to be you get
a bigger space right so the dimension of
this space is strictly or at least as
big as V okay so and he proved that you
know given my operator given my quantum
operator then the capacities bigger
zero if and only if this matrices are
ranked non-decreasing okay so that's a
combinatorial condition that gives you
the capacity bigger than zero and the
cool observation here that if you know
some invariant theory you know that
essentially what we're doing here is
Hubert Mumford okay but since we didn't
know invariant theory at that point we
didn't know you know in Garba didn't
know he was doing Hilbert Mumford right
so it's so a1 up to am is rank
decreasing which means that there is a
space that gets shrunk if and only if in
some basis they have a common all all
these matrices have a common Hall
blocker right because simply I if my
matrices are rank decreasing I just look
at my spaces after a change of basis all
of those matrices will have to have a
huge block of zeros okay so the
generalization of this Hall blocker and
is not an accident okay so okay now we
have this condition and how do we lower
bound the capacity can we use this
condition somehow to lower bound the
capacity okay so quick reminder what is
the capacity remember the capacity is
the infimum over all the determinants of
t of x such that the determinant of X
equal to 1 let's just normalize right
and what we want to prove is that the
capacity of T is bigger than 0 implies
that the capacity is lower bounded by
this inverse exponential
now let me give you this is a integer
yeah yeah it's very important to it's
very important to say that you know
these matrices are integral exactly
otherwise I mean you can get as close as
you want from from being 0
it's enough now it should work good but
just by putting ratings be just to see
yeah yeah I don't know we can talk about
it maybe you can ask me these questions
you can say how does the capacity pend
on the matrices this lower I mean if you
say they're integers then you get this
bound their own defenses oh yeah yeah at
some point you're gonna use an integer
which is not zeros at least what yeah
yes exactly
another yeah yeah we will yeah we can
prove we can give we can give bound to
me it's a function of the entries of the
matrices right so we just need this yeah
the one is just gonna be like coming the
exponent here yeah yeah so that's not so
okay let's do the basic case that the
unit did okay so suppose like what is
the easiest case of a rank non
decreasing tuple of matrices okay is
that let's say that one of these
matrices let's say a one is invertible
then you know you're not shrinking the
rank of any one right because V gets
mapped to some other you know space of
dimension just the same so in this case
we know that T of X okay it's bigger in
this positive semi-definite sense then
this matrix a 1 X a 1 dagger right we
know because they're just removing the
other sums right which implies that the
determinant of T X is greater greater
than or equal than the determinant of a1
X a 1 transpose conjugate transpose
right so in this case well since the
determinant of X is 1 you know and we
know well the determinant of this guy is
equal to the determinant of a1 squared
and a 1 square a 1 is an integral matrix
we know that this quantity is greater
than or equal to 1 okay so if I have one
invertible matrix I'm done right I know
how to lower bound capacity okay
now what is the next best like the next
basic case suppose that a 1 up to M span
an invertible matrix which leonid also
did in his paper okay then Anisa lemma
is if I pick a unitary matrix B ok in cm
or a cm okay then you know if I make
this matrices CI which are the son
which are the linear combinations with
the coefficients of the eighth row of
the matrix B okay then this operator
here TB okay is equal to my operator T
of X okay this change of basis preserves
my prayer my quantum operator is exactly
the same okay
so now if they spend an invertible
matrix then you can cook up a unitary
matrix B okay so and this guy is like
where the first row all of the elements
are rational and they have a small
denominator okay
such that C 1 okay is this linear
combination of a J's which is an
invertible matrix so essentially you can
make an invertible matrix okay with some
integer coefficients which is nice okay
we rational coefficients but the
denominator is very small so once you
have this matrix you know that T of X is
equal to this operator after a change of
basis okay but now this operator
remember we fall back to the case where
we have only one invertible matrix right
so then you know the determinant of T of
X is greater than the determinant of
this of c1 squared okay but now C 1
square is a rational matrix the
denominator is Q so you have that you
know my capacity is bigger than 1 over Q
to the 2n which is fine right okay so
these are the two basic cases now what
about the general case where TX is rank
non decreasing what are we doing this
case it was done different not the way
that say actually it was done using the
potential function which is like
permanent using the rotate what is a
Chasse
Kelly but it's quantum permanent and you
get so dead thing is always it's either
zero or integer and that is responsible
for existence of that no single method
okay and there is a relationship between
capacity and dead guy and a scandal
three yeah so since that proof is tricky
you know I didn't fit in this life but
yeah it was done differently back okay
so the general case is so the T is rank
non-decreasing right so okay and now to
finish the proof now we need to you know
cook up a different operator that we can
bound the capacity okay because well you
know we need to somehow prove we did
somehow you know if T is bringing on
decreasing the strategy now is well I
showed you two basic cases rights over
me I hope that is to reduce to those
basic cases so how can we come up from
an operator I take this this operator T
I want to come up with another operator
such that the capacity of this other
operator is smaller than my capacity of
T right but at the same time that
operator has some invertible matrix in
there span right that's how we continue
to like generalize this proof okay so
now for to do that I'll just define what
there's a tensor of two quantum
operators okay so if I have two
operators t1 and t2 of different
dimensions okay and they're given like T
is given by sum of a IJ X a I J and I'm
summing over J now I is 1 or to define
this operator T 1 2 as the tensor of T 1
and T 2 and this operator T 1 2 is given
by the matrices a1 I tensor a 2 J so if
I have a 1 up to am and B 1 up to B M my
new operator you take all the pairs and
it answered them ok so that's my new
quantum operator ok so is an easily
adjust by definition but just by the
definition of capacity which is an
infimum over a bunch of things that the
capacity of this operator of this new
operator T 1/2 is less than or equal
then the capacity of the first operator
T 1 to the power n 2 times the capacity
of the operator T 2 to the power and
one okay I can show this since it's very
okay so I mean what is the definition of
the capacity 41 - right
so is the infimum over all Y such that
determinant of Y is equal to 1 right and
you know Y is positive definite of
dimension and 1 & 2 right and then I
have what the determinant of this T of Y
T 1/2 of Y but what is T 1/2 of Y is
essentially sum of a I tens or BJ my Y
AI tens or BJ don't you get transpose
right
but this hmm right it's less than or
equal then if I take the infimum over
all matrices so let me put X here sorry
and if I take Y which is N 1 by N 1 and
if I take that which is positive
definite of dimension and to the
determinant of this - er you know one
and I take the determinant over some of
a I tens of EJ and here instead of
having X I have only X's of a specific
form and this X is exactly like X tends
or Y sorry is white energy
right then you can see how this is
splits exactly into the capacity of the
first one which is T 1 to the N 2 times
the capacity of T 2 to the N 1 ok so
this it just comes from the definition
of infimum right I'm just taking a
subset so yes the cool thing which is
harder to prove is that this is actually
equal okay so but we don't need that
further proof right we only need the
really easy side so to get a good lower
bound on the capacity now is enough to
say that if my T is rank non-decreasing
I can come up with some other operator T
Prime for some dimension D ok and my
dimension needs to be exponential okay
such that T tends or T prime has an
invertible matrix in there span right
because then we know how to lower bound
the capacity of this operator and I know
this bound okay yeah good question so
far right and I need and I need right
and I need the matrices that define my
operator T to be integral let's say yeah
not too big okay and for that we need
some invariant theory okay so underlying
all this you know finding this
invertible matrix there is something
very theory going on so let me just give
you a basic invariant here for this
setting which is I give you a group G ok
think of G is being SL N squared and it
acts on a 1 up to a n by this math fry
multiplication that we had before okay
so as I change the group a little bit
but you know it's essentially everything
is is the same so ok I'm acting on this
matrix by left-right multiplication and
the null cone problem okay is the
following given this vector of matrices
okay is there a sequence of scalings of
left and right scaling such that at this
limit the whole all of these matrices go
to 0 ok can i scale these points all the
way down to 0 this is the null cone
problem ok this is defined by Hubert
back to any much more generality or much
less generally it depends on how you see
it
and as a result by
you know there it's an environment
zubkov okay I have the names here oh I
don't have the names okay so so all
these people they prove that you know
this tuple of matrices is in the null
cone if and only if this tuple of matrix
is ranked non-decreasing okay but one
cool thing about it is that these matrix
this tuple of matrices rank
non-decreasing if and only if this
determinant of sum of a I tends RBI for
any matrices VI that you pick okay of
the same dimension is equal to zero okay
for all the BIS
so it's an if and only if so if my
operator is rank increasing then it must
be the case that there exists some B's
for some dimension okay
such that this determinant will be
nonzero and what does that mean that
means that this tends our operator that
I constructed will have an invertible
matrix in there span the integrality is
gone but for a computer science is not
because this determinant is a polynomial
I mean if you think of this determinant
as determined as a polynomial with
coefficients in these matrices B I if
there are coefficients right if your
problem is nonzero then if you you know
plug it in values from a large enough
grid right like you will find a non zero
there right which is essentially the
fundamental theorem of algebra you
cannot like have a lot of the - Paul
yeah yeah yeah that gives yeah so you
can pick the entries here so this is a
polynomial where the degrees are gonna
be like nd you can find a neat like up
to integers N and times D plus 1 you can
find everything so the integers are not
so big but gorebyss has a so there's a
way that's not important and we'll talk
about it next week right I'm the cool
proofs yeah so okay so yeah I was going
to advertise this yeah so okay so we can
find a nice matrices because you know we
can we can just use the fundamental
theorem of algebra and but Dirksen's
showed that you know remember we need an
exponential bound and this is a really
deep theorem by Dirk
that it is enough to take D to be
exponential in n here okay so you don't
need to look at at some dimension if he
gave an effective bound for the
dimension of the matrices they need to
look at okay and this will be important
for us but as we're bit saying like we
you know with Titan this analysis
because we know this this polynomial we
don't need the rickson's bound you just
need Hubert's finiteness yeah we don't
even need that actually that's the cool
thing the cool thing is that like we are
able to you know remove this and we are
only able to use finiteness of degrees
of this yeah so there in FN we don't
need a fact nervous here yeah yeah
so again if you just know that they
exist those bees of some dimension as
much you you will get that bond on the
capacity yeah so you know and that and
that will be presented in the coup
proofs okay like next week I don't know
when but we'll do it so okay but here
let's just use the Dirksen's bound
because it makes our life easier okay so
we just need to take D exponential and
if we take the exponential we can find
this matrices B you know with size with
the entries like n times this okay oh no
no no yeah yeah no I mean he uses comma
colonies of you know this is this is the
general theory of the for any reductive
group like this bound will it gives a
defective Vanya essentially combination
of some linear algebra those Joseph Choi
the iterations yeah but there's
something this is a general result is a
really deep result so it's much that
this is just Dirk's and specialize to
this group action I mean yeah I'm saying
you know okay so now if we put things
together now in a nutshell how do we
analyze this algorithm we have a
operator T and we know that capacity
oh is it different from zero there okay
so
No okay so capacity is okay let's say
let's negate everything kind of
everything here
so capacity is different from zero if
and only if my matrices are ranked non
decreasing which means that they are not
in the null cone okay which means that
there is a D such that this determinant
is different from zero so my matrices I
have a new vertical matrix and I can
find these bees very nicely
okay so dilemma is okay so take t1 given
by this matrices a1 take T to be a
Priven by these matrices B I there are
different from 0 okay and take the up
the operator T given by the Taser
operator of T 182 by the easily mer we
have that the capacity of this operator
is that you could then the product of
these two capacities but if we normalize
right we know that this capacity of T 2
let's normalize our operators T 1 and T
2 we know that this is less than or
equal to 1 right so in particular the
capacity of my original Parader
is less than or equal to the capacity of
the tensor square root of D 2
okay that's why the degree being big
doesn't matter so much because we're
taking that square root to the degree in
the lemma 2 which is what we proved is
that if I have an operator such that
they spend any variable matrix then
their capacity is lower bounded by 2 to
the minus n poly log n ok so then this
gives you a theorem that if T is given
by a tuple of matrix which is rank non
decreasing so the capacities bigger than
0 then it must be bigger than this
quantity okay so we get our effective
bound okay and with this we'll get a
polynomial time algorithm for operator
scale okay but what the cool thing is is
that you know this algorithm the
Gurewitz came up with right we can use
it to approximate capacity right we can
approximate capacity within 1 plus
epsilon multiplicative factor and how do
we do it well I mean every time you're
scaling you just keep track of the
scaling these scalars are multiplicative
anyways right
you can keep composing them and there is
another result as well that also curve
it's proved which generalizes is
something from the matrix scaling that
means that if you're very close to being
doubly stochastic then your capacity is
very close to 1
okay that's why if you scale to very
close to doubly stochastic you're also
approximating capacity okay and if you
keep track of the skin is you know that
the capacity is the product of the
determinants of all the scale is they
used times the capacity of your original
prater
so if you scale t0 to W stochastic you
have t0 times something that you know is
1 plus minus Epsilon okay 1 between 1
and 1 minus absolute right ok so you
know this can be used to approximate
capacity and it's nice and deterministic
now let's talk about brass complete
inequalities okay so what are those
that's shift gears now if your iron now
you can come back so ok so essentially
brass complete inequalities are the
following family of proposed
inequalities ok so I give you matrices B
I now I'm on the real so they map RN to
RN I okay these are surjective so an
eyes are less than or equal to n and I
gave you positive numbers P 1 up to p.m.
okay so my matrices are B 1 up to BM and
these numbers are attached to the B eyes
they are positive numbers and we have
the following functional inequality for
all integrable functions fi which are
non negative
okay I have the integral of the product
of F is when I apply bi to X so remember
the X lives on RN I'm shrinking down to
our Ni and I'm applying fi it's less
than or equal to some constant times the
1 of P I norms of these functions okay
and essentially the question is suppose
I give you this this BL datum ok this
brass complete date on this set of
matrices and these weights okay the
question is for which constant C does
this inequality hold if at all right so
in in simple terms is how do we prove
inequalities I mean we prove
inequalities left and right some people
do we'll do that for a living right in
it so we you know so how do we prove
those inequalities okay so let me just
let's just see some examples of
inequalities that fall within this
framework so for example cauchy-schwarz
that we know and love
right so for all integral functions we
know that the integral the product of F
1 F 2 is less than or you could than L 2
norms the product of the L 2 norms right
holders inequality which generalizes
cauchy-schwarz is again the integral of
the product is lesser than the product
of this 1 over P I norms right now some
other inequalities like Loomis whitney
inequality okay so suppose that I give
you a body in three dimensions and then
I project this body onto every two
dimensions okay
then the volume of this body is less
than reckoned in the cube root of the
volume of V 1 e 2 e 3 the volume of the
area of the projections okay so if you
look in pictures which I should have
done before is you know there you go you
have this body you project and then the
volume is less than even in the root of
these three products ok so the
functional version of this is for all
integral functions fi of the projections
is less than or equal to L 2 norms of
the integral of the FIS ok so you can
see how all of these inequalities are
essentially sub cases of brass complete
and so far we're being very lucky that
this constant here so how is always 1
it's kind of magical right and there's
another one which is sheer slammer which
you know again generalizes Loomis
Whitney and there's an equivalent
entropic version but anyway so this is
just for us to see like how does
inequalities pop up everywhere okay so
this BL datum okay the set of matrices
and the set of positive numbers will be
called feasible if this inequality holds
with some finite constant remember that
see if we can put in a see there that's
finite then we will say that this
inequality actually holds we have an
inequality right and this optimal see
that you can put in in the inequality
which was one for all the other cases
right will be called the brass complete
constant and now denoted by BL of B P
okay B all my data so you know the the
best inequality can hope for is less or
even than this BL times the product of
the norms okay okay so lead in the 90s
he proved that the maximizers of you
know if this holes like this will be
tight
you know when you plug in F is being
oceans okay
but now if the Pfizer gorshins what
happens well you know this guy becomes
one over the determinant of Y and
therefore you can come up with a formula
for the breast complete constant okay so
the breast complete constant will be the
supremum over all the a1 up to a.m.
which are positive definite okay of this
quantity yeah if it is finite if it is
finite is yeah exactly exactly so
deciding if a breast complete datum is
finite is essentially deciding if the
supremum is finite right it's stop
rebounding this so you know but if you
remember the first half of the talk
right like this looks an awful lot like
capacity right because you have you know
some determinants here or maybe some
determinants here right so this ratio of
determines in you're applying something
to this matrices AI okay let's see
something else that looks a lot like you
know our problem so in 2005
you know bennett Carberry kristin tao
they characterize the set of maps of
datum such that this inequality such
that the supreme um okay such that an
inequality holds
okay such that this is bounded by some
finite constant in their
characterization was as follows so if n
ok so the matrices remember be the
matrices be i are mapping and to ni okay
and the peas are the other the positive
integers or the positive numbers so this
datum is feasible which means that you
have an inequality if and only if the
following holds n is equal to the
weighted sum of the NIS okay and for all
subspaces v you have that the dimension
of V is less than or equal than the
weighted sum of these dimensions of Biv
okay so
yes but is equal to n it has to be equal
to n that's the dimension for the second
C yes yes
and okay you know if you remember this
runs subspace right
there's also looking a lot like shrunk
subspace right so and an interesting
thing about this this work of Bennett at
all is that you know if you fix just the
matrices B you know the linear
projections the projections bi ok and
you let P B be the set of all the peas
that satisfy all these above conditions
okay this is a polytope ok so which
means that if I give you any linear
transformations you have an inequality
if and only if this P is lying inside of
a polytope ok so we have some polyhedra
thing giving a lot of inequalities right
and you have obviously I mean you might
say well but these are infinitely many
constraints but they're not really
infinite because these dimensions are
integers between 1 and n right so you
know so you do have finitely many
constraints ok now ok so it's looking an
awful lot like capacity sounding a lot
like capacity now let's scream that this
is a capacity right so in 89 and 90 8
ball and bars they define this datum BP
is called geometric if it satisfies the
following conditions ok one hbi is a
projection ok so I have the bi bi
transpose is equal to the identity ok so
each bi is a projection and they
satisfied as I isotropic condition which
means that this weighted sum of P I bi
transpose bi is equal to the big
identity ok so ok now and what ball
proved is that if your datum is
geometric then you have an inequality
and your inequality has constant exactly
1 so for example all of the first
inequalities that I showed to you in my
example they're all geometric data ok so
you can go and check and you'll see that
they're all geometric and that's why it
was always one it was not luck right so
not
question is can we convert efficiently
any feasible BL datum to this geometric
case if we could we can try to show some
finiteness algorithmically right because
it was an open question in BC CT if
there was an algorithm which is not
exponential to decide whether the
default well they didn't even have an
algorithm because you don't know how to
you know you know there's a polytope out
there but you don't know how to define
it because you don't know how to choose
like what inequalities will hold okay
you don't know how to pick the vector
space so they're like is there any
actually algorithm is there any
effective procedure okay let alone
polynomial time is there any effective
procedure that can decide if a datum is
feasible or not and with this
description they couldn't do anything
okay so so very search of an algorithm
right and one strategy could be well
okay I take of if if a datum is feasible
I can convert it to a geometric one okay
so okay so this gives us an escaping
algorithm right so what is my data I
have my datum B P and what is gonna be
my algorithm okay so take my collection
of matrices okay if they're not
projection matrices make them all
projection so you fix the projection
case right and it can fix by multiplying
them all on the Left now now you're
gonna make you may mess up the isotropic
position but if you messed up there's a
truck as a tropic position then you just
fix their isotropic position okay now
you mess up the projection condition and
you keep doing this okay
so okay if you fix one you disturb the
other but again just keep doing this
alternately
right so and we're gonna show that this
works and why because this is
essentially capacity right this is a
screaming like this is saying well you
know breast complete constant is saying
well call me capacity right and so we're
gonna show that this algorithm of fixing
projection and I thought 2p it will work
okay but how do we analyze it well you
know usually math if it looks like a
duck and it quacks like a duck we can
prove there is a dragon right so you
know we're gonna reduce this to
operators game
so okay so how do we compute it so let's
so we have our matrices bi and our
numbers CI over D okay and now I have
five minutes so great I can you know do
the proof real quick and the proof of
this
okay the intuition is is the same is in
a same way how you kind of reduced you
know matrix scaling to operator scaling
okay matrix K is an operator scaling
procedure because we came up with these
operators right with matrices AI so how
do we come up with this eight matrices
AI now well remember we have this bis
and hbi if I put the brass complete in a
more capacity way I have some of P I and
then I have this bi transpose AI right
then I have my infimum is over all this
major let me put X I here I have the
infimum over all positive definite x AI
bi over the product of the determinants
of the AI right so let's suppose now
that all of these P is they're just
essentially one over D okay let's just
do this basic case the rest you know how
to figure out so VI is equal to 1 over D
okay so how do we construct these other
operators well notice that I need to get
VI has to act on a different matrix
right so let's suppose that we have a
matrix like this X 1 X 2 X M right so
how does my operator I have to come up
with a big operator how does this
operator act on this matrix to only
extract X 1 well I simply put B 1
transpose here and everything 0 here so
this is an N by whatever ND matrix where
I only put B 1 here once I multiply so
let me say that this is C 1 so once I
multiply C 1 times this big matrix X ok
and I multiply by C 1 transpose what do
I get
I get exactly V 1 transpose
x1 you want
right so then my operator will
essentially be a collection of these
matrices c1 would be B 1 0 0 0 C 2 will
be 0 B 2 0 0 0 and so on and so forth
ok so that's essentially a similar
reduction from that we did from matrix
came in to operator scaling will give
you some quantum operator such that that
operator is ranking on decreasing
exactly when these conditions hold and
the double stochasticity is exactly the
isotropy in the projection ok so you get
that magically for free you might think
wow did the so elementary why didn't
anyone see well you know and so now from
this reduction we came up with an
operator that captures the feasibility
problem for the brass complete constant
ok but not only that it captures to
compete captures this infimum here so I
can actually compute use my algorithm to
approximate the capacity to actually
compute what the constant is I can not
only decide feasibility but I can
compute it in polynomial time ok there's
a polynomial time but it's not really
polynomial because you know this D the
dependence in D is really large that's
why the ducts become a dragon right
because you know it's not optimal so ok
so with this we compute the brass
complete cost and we decide finiteness
and you know this reduction here it
looks very simple and very nice but it
has connections to quiver
representations so if you know what I'm
talking about if you don't you don't
need to worry about it but it's
essentially the reduction from the star
quiver to the Kronecker quiver ok so
it's really nice and we when we did it
we didn't know but we learned that is
exactly the same and yeah so there may
be more connections there that are still
not explored so I'm gonna finish with
some open questions and the question is
well can we get more applications of
these scaling problems you know we saw
here for optimization and we saw for
even functional analysis there's this
unexpected application right and another
question is can we get different in the
new inequalities to generalize the
capacity for non abelian group actions
because this capacity in invariant
theory you can define in a much more
general term okay and Gurewitz he
already has the capacity for hyperbolic
polynomials like this inequalities and
you know can we get more inequalities
can we get some more inequalities for
these capacities for even for operator
scaling for example can we have some von
der Vardhan conjecture for for operator
scaling capacity okay and what about
general group actions can we get this
von der Vaart and like can we really
generalize as much as possible this
wonder of ardent for using variant
theory let me let me slide something
under the rug yeah okay cool yeah and
the other one is well can we get more
brass complete pipe inequalities for
other Quivers for example okay so these
are open questions that yeah we really
don't know and yeah thanks I'd like to
[Applause]
yeah we can if we computer ourselves
cases you just say yeah principle we can
it the algorithm is very easy I mean the
thing is it depends on how the D blows
up right but usually the examples we saw
that the D is very small the fraction is
very small right so we can just
computing them
you know Bubba you can talk about you
can tell me what it is and I can code
them today so it's not I mean the
algorithm is so simple it's a yeah I
mean we haven't we haven't yes
yeah exactly if they all have a common
denominator that is small then
definitely this algorithm runs really
fast that's the problem and all the
inequality that we saw they have this
case but we didn't but all of them we
know what the brass complete constant is
right but you I'll be happy to know one
that people are trying to ok ok there's
a new brass complete Constance yeah rich
it's a very good question so so the
question was if the capacity is actually
zero can I actually find this shrunk
subspace right and the answer is yes but
not through what we do we the analytic
approach we cannot find this but in at
the same time that we gave this operator
scaling algorithm analysis there were
another group of people who gave an
algebraic algorithm to decide whether
capacity 0 or not and there they can
produce the shrunk subspace so in a
sense yes so we can but not by this
algorithm is a different one by Ivana's
Chow and Subramanian you see the work of
customs and people like that where they
have lots of qumar ago which is got some
other flavor when a diagnostic mind
tricks you back crosses one way you
switch you just keep on doing that so I
think this is very simple yeah because
it's not conjugation is not there
gadgets I will actionbar conjugation
yeah but then they are so right so yeah
but yeah but I think yeah I think so
using Hamiltonian mechanics so as to see
how quickly it converges
of course you don't have this problem
yeah yeah no but this is this agent yeah
it's interesting I think we now may be
able to do it because now we have
general group actions we can do scaling
for general group actions and then you
know this is a scaling problem we can do
it so yeah but I okay well maybe you can
talk about I want to know how fast can
they do it if they can be
they've designed was this qrl okay so
okay good so we can talk about it later
yeah so yeah we can now but let's the
diagnose a shoe well I think it's cute
cute cool
[Music]
okay okay before let me just give some
advertisements because we need more hits
and our you know Paige so there was an
amazing workshop at the IAS about
scaling problems you should check it out
go to yes and look for it and there's a
survey and the link codes on my webpage
about all this scaling algorithm sorry
the commercial yeah yeah